hello everyone and welcome to some
premium action on board one from this
year's uh Aid Grand Swiss this is the
second round and it's Fabiano corana uh
who is the top seed of the tournament
trying to break 2800 again and even
though he already qualified for the
candidates tournament he's just here uh
playing incredible chess he's facing
Hans smok andiman former 2700 player so
again former 2700 versus former 2800
player and it's quite uh quite an
amazing game so let's check it out Fabby
has the wi pieces and he opens with Pawn
to E4 uh for those of you who are just
joining in uh in round one we've shown
that game on the channel Fabby defeated
Ian shich was a brilliant attack on uh
the or rather brilliant Sicilian Defense
and shich attack with the wi pieces and
nean defeated the international master
from uh International master from Norway
elham Amar uh so let's check out this
round two game E4 E5 we will have the
Berlin defense Knight F3 Knight to C6
Bishop to B 5 and Knight to F6 uh Hans
goes for the Berlin defense and he says
all right you're the you're the
legendary chess player Fabian corana you
defeat my Berlin defense we have Pawn to
D3 by Fabby Bishop to C5 and now Bishop
captures and C6 D captures and now Pawn
to H3 uh there are some more popular
moves here like Knight B to D2 and
castles Fabby goes for Pawn to H3 first
we have Knight to
D7 uh you have to defend the D E5 Pawn
somehow and now Knight to C3 we have
castles and Bishop to E3 attacking the
bishop here and Bishop to D6 here is a
new move it's a completely new move
there are some games where Rook d8 was
played but after Bishop to D6 it is now
as of move eight that we have a
completely new game so okay Fab castles
uh we have Rook to E8 and now Knight to
D2 the Knight is now coming to C4 to put
pressure on the dark sare Bishop on D6
we have Knight to f8 by Hans uh Knight
Knight to C4 and now Knight to G6 so a
bit of a horsing around right there Pawn
to D4 and now Bishop to E6 uh if you're
wondering about uh what happens if you
capture if you capture on D4 then we go
Knight captures on D6 and after C
captures Queen captures on D4 and now
okay you can play something like F5 but
now even Pawn to F4 and it's um nothing
spectacular for example Queen to E7 now
even Rook a to D1 and after Pawn to D5
you will get the advance the the Ponto
E5 it can be played uh but um uh Hans
decides not to he goes for Bishop to E6
first puts pressure on the Knight on C4
Knight captures on D6 Fabby wins the
bishop pair or rather he already gave up
his Bishop now he eliminates hans's
Bishop as well C captures and now Pawn
to D5 challenging the bishop C captures
we have Knight captures and now Queen to
D7 uh we have Queen to D3 and Bishop
captures on D5 we have Queen captures
and now Knight to E7 kicking away the
White Queen Queen back to D3 and now
Pawn to D5 so hun did pretty much
everything now he executes D5 and he's
going to enjoy uh at least an equal
position we have e captures Queen
captures offering a queen trade and Fa
says all right let's trade Rook F to D1
and Hunt says sure let's trade but not
on your not on your terms Rook e to d8
he wants to trade everything off on the
D5 square and now Queen to E2 Fabby
declines the queen trade and he now
brings The Rook into the game so The
Rook is now controlling the dile
attacking the black queen queen to A5
and now Queen to G4 so Queens will not
be getting traded off at least not right
now and um uh now the question is should
you trade Rooks well if you go for Rook
captures on D1 then Rook captures on D1
you give fabbi the the open defile and
if you now play Queen captures on A2 you
grab the Rook then Queen to D7 is
already winning there's is um not much
you can do here the the Knight is
attacked and also Queen d8 will be the
threat of Checkmate so you can't really
defend against both so after Queen to G4
we have Queen to A6 uh and now we have
Rook captur on d8 Rook captures and Rook
to D1 offering a trade of the other pair
of the Rooks as well and you could do
this but if you go for Rook captures on
D1 then Queen captures and let's say
Knight to C6 then Queen to D7 is again
very very annoying uh much too active
for white so instead Hans brings The
Rook back Rook to A8 looks like a very
weird passive move but you want to get
your queen inter game and you don't want
to hang your A7 Pawn so he has to move
the queen then he has to play something
like A6 or B6 and then he will
reintroduce The Rook into the game so
here we have Rook to D7 of course Fabby
takes advantage of this and brings his
Rook to a seventh rank or as we say it
he transforms his Rook into a pig and
now Knight to G6 uh if you def def now
with Rook to E8 again uh you will just
get terribly checkmated Rook captures
Rook captures and queen to C8 will be
Checkmate after The Rook blocks so
instead after Rook to D7 Knight to G6
and now Queen to F3 Fabby now puts
pressure on the F7 pawn and also some
pressure on the B7 Pawn so what can Hans
do he plays Queen captures on A2
captures the pawn and defends the F7
pawn and Fabby just plays Pawn to B3
what are you playing now uh you have to
defend somehow If you defend with the
Rook if Rook to f8 then Bishop C5 is
very annoying so Hans can't really do
that Hans plays Knight to h8 uh he
defends the F7 Pawn with the Knight but
now just Queen captures on B7 again
putting pressure on F7 putting pressure
on A7 and putting pressure on The Rook
on A8 so Rook to E8 and now we have
Queen to C6 threatening all sorts of
discoveries as Queen captures on E8
would be quite painful so uh and also if
you play something like A6 if you want
to also save your Pawn then Rook to C7
uh will be just winning there's really
not not a good way to deal with both
threats of Queen captures on8 and Rook
to C8 so after Queen to C6 um hun says
all right I have to deal with my back
rank issues I will play Pawn to H6 and
now Fabby claims back the material U he
plays a rook captur on A7 now he's even
up a pawn queen to B1 check by Hans King
to H2 and Rook to f8 again defending on
on F7 uh we have Queen to C4 now again
putting pressure on F7 so yeah you can't
even start advancing the pawn with F5
and now Rook to d8 we have Pawn to B4 fa
is up only one Pawn but he does have two
connected um pass pawns on the queen
side and B4 uh well wins the game more
often than not uh Rook to B8 by Hans
situation on the clock is 17 minutes for
Fabby and only 9 minutes for Hans and
they still have to make seven more moves
to reach time control and um Fabby is
sort of inviting Hans to play Rook to D1
but if you go Rook to D1 to maybe try
some Rook H1 action uh Queen to C8 check
King H7 and now just Queen to F5 with
check now if you go back then you just
get checkmated so you have to block with
the Knight and then Queen captures
threatening Rook to G Queen captures and
G7 Checkmate and yes you will give this
one check but after King G3 there's just
no good uh continuation here so you will
have to resign so that's why after B4
Rook back to B8 by hunts now threatening
the B4 pawn and Fabby just defends it
pawn to C3 we have Rook back to d8 and
now we have Queen to A2 um sorry Queen
to A2 by Fabi could also start by
advancing the pass B Pawn but Fabby
wants to minimize hans's counterplay so
Hans of course has to decline the trade
he is down material and now we have Pawn
to B5 Fabby starts advancing his past B
Pawn now um both players are now around
an 8 minutes on the clock and they still
have to make four more moves to reach
time control we have King to H7 hunts
now prepares Pawn to F5 if he can get
Pawn to F5 Pawn to F4 in uh he's still
in the game uh Fabby plays B6 and pawn
to F5 now who is faster well Fabby plays
Queen to A4 uh you could also play B7
but then Rook to B8 is very annoying as
um it is winning but still you have to
you know work your way around that
because the a square is covered by by
the rook and by the pawn uh you have to
play something like Queen to B3 then
Queen to B for trade queens and then win
the game so uh Fabby decides to trade
Queens right away he plays Queen to A4
we have Queen to B1 by hunts and now
Queen to
H4 so what uh what do you do here well
there are simply too many threats
uh just Queen captur on H6 followed by
Queen captures on G7 is already
Unstoppable and The Rook on d8 is
hanging so the only way to defend both
of these threats is to play Rook to D6
uh the defends the rook and the H6 Pawn
which Hans did H but now just Queen to
D7 by Fabby attacks the The Rook on D6
also attacks the the pawn on G7 Rook to
G6 was played uh getting the Rook into
the attack but it doesn't matter just
Queen captures on E5 and he was in this
position on a move 41 upon reaching time
control that Hans miman resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here so he's now up two pawns and there
is zero counterplay Hans can um even
even try here maybe Queen to F1 he can
threaten Checkmate but after a simple G3
there's nothing you cannot play F4 you
can't really move the Rook otherwise
you're getting checkmated uh if you do
nothing B7 B8 gets a new Queen into the
game so there are many many ways you can
win this doesn't doesn't really matter
all that much what you play even if you
took this position and played it against
hunt you would defeat him like 10 times
like maybe okay maybe nine times out of
10 that's how how good this position is
and what does this mean for fabiana's
rating because okay he's 2786 until the
next next rating list but on the live
rating list he was uh uh he he needed
less than three points to reach 2800 so
I will now check because they still
didn't update it when I started
recording so he is now he's now on 2801
so yes Fabby does uh break 2800 on the
live ratings and now only Magnus Carlson
and Fabiana corana are rated over 2800
at least in the live ratings we'll see
if Fabiano can keep this up uh but he
did Crush every won in the US CH
Championship he's now on two out of two
basically punishing you know the the the
the smallest of mistakes uh he is um he
he's coming for for Magnus once again
not not for him as he's not the world
champion ding Len is not world champion
but maybe for his rating as Magnus did
lose quite a lot of rating now uh who
who knows what will happen maybe we are
looking at at the the second or third
great rise of Fabiano corana where he
will be the highest rated player in the
world we'll see what happens uh so yeah
uh that's the game I hope you guys
enjoyed it not a lot you can do here
basically you are without a move so of
course Hans resigned uh I would like to
thank paches Cali Daniel Taylor Mark
bamri grid words logical letters for iOS
and the John gear law office for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the Chess World uh so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your
day